as we speak tonight the Democratic Party
is drowning in a sea of scandal senator
Al Franken has been forced to issue
multiple apologies after now four women
have come forward to accuse him of
sexual misconduct
now the allegations include unwanted
kissing groping and earlier today
Franken apologized yet again but made it
clear he has no plans to step down watch
this I know that I've let a lot of
people down people of Minnesota my
colleagues my staff my supporters and
everyone who has counted on me to be a
champion for women if you had said you
know asked me two weeks ago would any
woman come forward with an allegation
like this I would have said no and so I
cannot speculate this is been a shock
and it's been extremely humbling I am
embarrassed I feel ashamed what I'm
gonna do is I'm I'm gonna start my job
I'm gonna go back to work I'm gonna work
as hard as I can
for the people of Minnesota and I'm
gonna start that right now you know I'm
someone who you know hugs people and I
you know and I've learned from these
these stories that some of in some of
these encounters I've crossed a line now
senator groper is not the only high
profile Democrat now facing sexual
harassment allegations the
longest-serving member of Congress John
Conyers is in hot water after new
revelations show that he settled one
sexual harassment case out of court
paying a former staffer not out of his
own money but out of congressional
office funding another congressional
aide has also accused the Democratic
congressman of verbally abusing her and
even said Conyers once held a meeting in
his underwear
this weekend Conyers issued a statement
announcing his decision to step down
as the ranking member of the House
Judiciary Committee but Conyers said he
has no plans of resigning from office
writing in part quote I very much look
forward to vindicating myself and my
family before the House Committee on
ethics of course there's no shortage of
Democrats in Congress that are coming
out to defend Franken and Conyers
they're Democrats all of a sudden they
have discovered well due process and not
rushing to judgment is a good thing
imagine that take a look should Franken
resign listen Al Franken has
acknowledged what he did was wrong and
it was wrong
he has also submitted his whole case to
the Senate Ethics Committee I think that
was the right thing to do do you think
congressman Conyers you sit with him on
judiciary should he resign well I think
the ethics process should proceed you
know senator Franken you've served with
them what do you think should happen to
him should he resign that's the question
that will have to be determined after
the investigation the House Ethics just
this afternoon announced an
investigation that John Conyers he needs
to be held accountable for whatever
happened should he stop that so let's
wait to see what the House Ethics ins
does your colleague Al Franken has been
accused do you think he should resign I
think that that is a distraction to be
talking about resignation do you now
think that your colleague Conyers should
resign from the house no I don't think
the rules are different from anyone else
House Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi is
also rushing to defend Conyers she's
saying oh no rush to judgment she's
actually calling for due process watch
this we are strengthened by due process
just because someone is accused and it
was that one accusation is it - I think
there has to be John Conyers is an icon
in our country he's done a great deal to
protect women violence against women
Abby you got to hide his settlement he
got to his accusers had to go through
all sorts of craziness so why is he
entitled to new due process well I in
this case no I we are talking about what
we have heard I've asked the ethics
committee to review that he has said
he'd be open he will cooperate with you
excuse me
believe I don't know who they are do you
they have not really come forward and
and that gets you don't know if you
believe the accusations what that's for
the Ethics Committee to review how I
stay inconsistent I say never rush the
judgment I say everybody deserves the
presumption of innocence and I stand by
that in this particular case but it is
funny the congresswoman Pelosi only
seems to care about due process but only
when Democrats are involved so in that
same interview Pelosi was asked about a
comment she made in 1998 then host of
Meet the Press Tim Russert asked her
about the investigation into Bill
Clinton this gets rather humorous but
sad why the silence when there have been
these allegations serious ones about
President Clinton well I'd like to say
that I think that the women of America
are speaking out about what they think
about this whole situation and the women
of America are just like other Americans
in that they value fairness with a value
privacy and do not want to see an a
person with uncontrolled power
uncontrolled time uncontrolled unlimited
money and investigating at the President
of the United States with inconsistent
statements like this can you really
trust the Democratic Party to be the
champion for women or they just playing
politics with the topic can the
Democratic party really stand for women
when it protected the Clintons for 30
years
who took millions and millions of
dollars from countries with the most
atrocious women's rights records and can
the Democratic Party really stand for
women when it supports a person for
president who we all know actively tried
to silence all of our husband's sexual
assault accusers and by the way even on
Meet the Press they called Bill Clinton
a predator with being accused of
predatory behavior the answers to us are
pretty simple now we turn our attention
to another top story tonight the lawyers
for former national security adviser
Michael Flynn are reportedly meeting
with members of Robert Mulder's team a
sign that a deal could in fact be in the
works tonight once again we are
investigating the investigators behind
this Russian collusion probe including
the Special Counsel himself Robert
Muller and one of his top prosecutors
Andrew Weitz
the LA Times this weekend out with a
brand new profile of Muller highlighting
many of his serious flaws now according
to the article quote Muller has a record
that shows a man of fallible judgment
who can be slow to alter his chosen
course now the article goes on to
criticize his handling of the 2001
anthrax case while Muller was serving as
the director of the FBI the report reads
quote his tenacious yet linear approach
to evaluating evidence led him to fumble
the biggest u.s. terrorism investigation
since 9/11 now of course this is the
very same Robert Muller who stood by and
did nothing when he was the director of
the FBI
while the controversial sale of uranium
one was being approved by Hillary
Clinton Eric Holder's and others in 2010
now keep in mind in 2009 the FBI had
evidence of Russian bribery linked to
uranium one remember a confidential
informant provided further evidence of a
potentially illicit deal those eighteen
months before where 20% of America's
uranium was at stake here all while the
United States faces a uranium shortage
so why didn't Robert Muller stop that
horrible deal now some are questioning
the motives behind who Muller chose to
staff the Russia investigation later
tonight you're going to meet a woman
named Sidney Powell she worked at the
DOJ for a decade she believes the that
one of Muller's top investigators andrew
Weissman has a documented history of
using strong-arm tactics to seek
convictions unethical behavior our own
colleague Greg Jarrett will also join us
tonight he did digging into Weissman's
past he came to the same conclusion
remember back during the Enron
accounting scandal Weissman
well he was a hard-charging prosecutor
on the task force that brought a
controversial obstruction of justice
case against the accounting firm Arthur
Andersen that eventually put that
company out of business
he cost tens of thousands of people
their jobs and it was all for nothing
because in 2005 the US Supreme Court
overturned the obstruction of justice
conviction in a nine zero unanimous
ruling but
that's not the only example of
Weissman's aggressive tactics resulting
in a case being overturned the
conviction of a business transaction
between Enron and Merrill Lynch it sent
people to jail was also reversed by the
fifth US Circuit Court of Appeals now
critics have also accused Weissman of
intimidating witnesses creating crimes
that don't even exist and in one case in
particular one case withholding evidence
that was expelled to defend it and just
like Muller Weissman is also tied to
this corrupt uranium one deal and the
ensuing cover-up Weissman ran the do J's
fraud section during the Russian bribery
scheme and Gregg Jarrett noticed that
his name his signature are on the bottom
of the plea agreement that was signed by
the Russian businessman involved in that
case so why in god's name would Muller
appoint Weissman with being this record
of being overturned to be involved in
the Russia investigation if we're going
to be entirely honest the entire Russia
collusion investigation may never even
have taken place if not for the complete
hysteria on the left from the moment
Donald Trump defeated Hillary on
November 8th of 2016 over the weekend
the president tweeted quote since the
first day I took office all you hear is
the phony Democratic excuse for losing
the election Russia Russia Russia
despite this I have the economy booming
and have possibly done more than any
10-month president make America great
again now the president is right to push
the significant economic triumphs that
have now taken place in the last 10
months we're going to get to more of
that good news in a minute but first I
want to offer a sincere message to
lawmakers in Washington despite setbacks
the House of Representatives well they
have actually gotten some work done
fighting for the President's agenda they
got the repeal and replace of Obamacare
they got the tax cut they got 413 other
bills and joint resolutions passed but
for the next three and a half weeks all
eyes will be on the ineffective US
Senate where we've seen a much different
story unfolding now of president Trump's
515 nominations civilian nominations
only 249 have yet to be approved in
almost a year
and of course we all remember the
Senate's failure to repeal Obamacare and
now a tax reform vote is looming but its
fate is totally uncertain tonight and
like many other pieces of crucial
legislation pushed by the Trump White
House all you have several Republican
senators standing in its way so tonight
we asked John McCain and Lisa Murkowski
bob Corker Jeff Flake the flake the
snowflake and others who might be
planning to kill the tax cut pill I have
a message for you
voters did not put you in office to do
nothing and vote no on everything the
American people put you in office to
solve difficult problems and get the job
done so you don't like something in the
tax bill fix it and I don't love
everything in this bill either but over
the next three and a half weeks all of
America is watching they expect a tax
reform bill one that lowers the
corporate rate brings back money and
jobs from overseas that gives a
middle-class tax cut repatriation money
also the millions of energy jobs that
will be created because we remember with
these cuts well that makes the opening
of factories in the u.s. possible a tax
reform bill that's going to spur
economic growth hopefully for decades to
come
no the Bill's not perfect but earlier
today Senator Rand Paul announced he
will support the Senate's tax reform
legislation like him I wish it went
further it's time for other lawmakers to
join them there's too much at stake do
you even care about the Forgotten men
and women in this country people in
poverty on food stamps out of work now
despite the Senate's inability to pass
laws and approve the president's picks
well the president he's working at the
speed of Trump and has for the last 10
months to get things done and of course
members of the lazy destroyed Trump
media aren't interested in doing their
job so we'll continue to do a forum take
a look at that screen right there here
are just some of the president's
accomplishments now there are so many it
would take us way too long to read them
all on top of the president's
accomplishments since he took office in
January look at the economic numbers
things are booming according to the
latest numbers available at October 261
thousand jobs created unemployment a
17-year low consumer confidence a
17-year high median existing home price
for all housing types in October 27
people's biggest investment well that's
up 8.7% from January of 2017 stock
market again all-time high and more
people are in the workforce than ever
and on the campaign trail President
Trump promised to make our economy great
well so far that's exactly what he's
doing
that's why the Senate needs to get off
their backsides and pass this tax reform
package is vital take a look at the
president pushing this tax cut earlier
today I think the tax bill is going very
well we had a meeting on it today it's
gonna be a tremendous tax cut the
biggest in the history of our country
you'll have to pay a lot less tax that's
okay but we're gonna have a tremendous I
think we're gonna have great receptivity
but if we win I think we'll probably
have a bipartisan bill meaning a number
of people are gonna come over but I'm
not so interested in that we're really
interested just in getting it passed
again it will be the biggest tax
reduction in the history of our country
it'll bring jobs it'll bring a lot of
income coming into the country buying
product etc and I think it's doing very
well so